تحولت الاحتجاجات إلى مشاهد فرح
وابتهاج في جميع أنحاء إيران هذا الأسبوع
، خرج الإيرانيون للاحتفال
بهزيمة بلادهم في كأس العالم كأس العالم
سريالية ، لكن بالنسبة للكثيرين بعد أن وصفوا
فريقهم بأن النظام القمعي الذي
هُزم لم يعد بإمكانه ادعاء
النصر بينما يقمع بعنف.
خاص بشعب
مهران سمك خرج في شوارع
مدينته بندر أنزلي في سيارته
وهو يطلق البوق احتفالاً عندما
أصيب برصاصة في رأسه ناشطون في مرصد
حقوق الإنسان لشبكة CNN أن
قوات النظام هي التي قتلت 27 عاماً
تنفي السلطات  قتل سماك وهم
يحققون في اقتباسه في أشياء مشبوهة
يقولون إن العديد من المشتبه بهم قد
أوقفوا التحقيقات التي أجرتها الحكومة الإيرانية
في غبار
المتظاهرين الشباب منذ سبتمبر تفتقر إلى
المصداقية والحياد
وفقًا للأمم المتحدة ، لا يُسمح لنا بالإبلاغ
من داخل إيران عن أولئك الذين يتحدثون.
يواجهنا السجن أو ما هو أسوأ مما يجعل من الصعب
علينا سرد قصص الضحايا وأولئك الذين
تركوا
تنشر منشورات حزن ساماك على إنستغرام مجرد
لقطة صغيرة لحياة انتهت قريبًا جدًا
شاب رياضي استمتع
بالحياة مع أصدقائه والرياضات المائية أثناء
نشأته ، لعب كرة القدم مع سعيد
عزة الله الآن لاعب وسط في
المنتخب الوطني الذي شارك هذه الصورة
حدادًا على طفولته  لقد كتب صديقًا ،
أتمنى أن نبقى دائمًا في نفس
العمر دون أي مخاوف دون أي كراهية
دون غيرة دون قتال لإحباط
بعضنا البعض بعد ليلة مريرة أخرى
الليلة الماضية ومع خبر
موتك ، اشتعل قلبي أكثر
في بعض الثور  المعزين في الدفن يهتفون
الموت للديكتاتور الوئام يجب أن يذهب
كل خسارة في الأرواح تجلب المزيد من الحزن
والغضب المزيد من التحدي
والتصميم لشعب يخاطر بكل شيء
في هذه المعركة الدموية من أجل الحرية